so these are the principles the
different ways in which lucky people
think and behave so we have they're open
to opportunities and when those
opportunities come along they make the
most of them and you saw that all the
time they're very flexible so they got
an end point they knew they wanted to i
don't know be successful or you know
financially well-off or whatever it was
but the way they were going to get there
they didn't really know they were
looking at the way the wind was blowing
and then setting sail to make the most
of that very flexible
folks
second they tend to trust their
intuition and when they get that gut
feeling they really do treat it as an
alarm bell and take it quite seriously
third they're optimists and so that
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy they
they kind of continue in the face of
failure and and so on and fourth and i
think it's probably the most important
principle uh they're extremely resilient
so when bad things happen they could
bounce back yeah you know i remember i
interviewed hundreds of lucky and
unlucky people one of them was this guy
that was in the lucky group and he came
in for two interviews between the into
interviews he'd fallen down the stairs
and broken his leg it's the second
interview he comes in with his leg and a
cast yeah
and i say i bet you don't consider
yourself quite so lucky now and he says
this wonderful answer which still sticks
with me he said you're kidding he said
you never know the impact of something
like this he said sure it's annoying at
the moment but he said last time i went
to hospital i fell in love with the
nurse there we were happily married 25
years later it was the best thing that
ever happened to me he said don't label
it bad luck you never know what's going
to come from this yeah it says
incredibly resilient sort of attitude
and so those are the four things the
opportunism uh the intuition the
optimism and the resilience and and is
that something that people can learn or
is it does it tend to be a sort of quote
innate
trait well that's a very good question
all of us are a mixture of
genes and the nature of nurture
basically
and i'm not very interested in the
nature
end of things
i'm not very interested in things that
can't change or don't change
so i think all of us can make the most
of our potential and that's the bit as a
social psychologist that fascinates me
the challenge is how do you do it how do
you do it and when i looked at these
self-help books i realized that this
stuff wasn't evidence-based people were
just making things up some of it might
be helpful some of it might not be
and so we started to come up with
interventions and test them okay and
that was the basis of life factor
which which is these things which
actually we know make a difference
because we've done the the studies to
support it hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day